[Applause]
thank you slightly overestimated how
tall I am
[Music]
there
to my
mom I knew from a very young age that I
was different we both did the way I'd
sort my toys that I'd insist on
different plates for different foods
birthday parties made me
anxious and by the time I was 4 years
old I I became so sure that if I didn't
hide my differences people wouldn't like
me so I became a version of myself I
thought those around me would
accept I became a mimic copying other
people imitating normal behavior and
suppressing anything weird for most
people these rules come naturally
automatically their faces match their
voices match their
feelings but I had to think about every
little
thing in the end I put so much effort
into this mask of normality that nobody
could even tell that I had
one when you're autistic masking
camouflaging it's a survival strategy
it's to avoid judgment or avoid bullying
it's a way to fit into the non-autistic
world I have masked with everybody in my
life
including you Mom I wanted to be the
perfect
child and I wanted to make you
proud but now I'm
tired it's exhausting pretending to be
normal over the
time I'm beginning to think it might be
time to embrace my authentic self to
show you the things you don't normally
see but I'm
scared
I'm worried that if I'm quiet and still
on my face doesn't match my feelings
then you'll think that I'm being
[Music]
rude I'm worried that if you see me
rocking back and forth or flapping my
hands then you'll think that I'm not
[Music]
okay and I'm worried that if you see me
S silent unable to
speak you'll think that I need
[Music]
fixing it might not come easily for me
straight
away but I'm ready to be
myself I hope you won't be
disappointed I love you always your
daughter
Flo
you right
yeah you love you I love
[Music]
you I want to scoop up the 5-year-old
you mhm me too and say it's okay yeah
and if we could turn the clock back and
I knew what I know today it would
be maybe I would have been able to give
you some reassurance about it's okay is
absolutely okay you
know all through my child childhood and
My Teenage life and my adult life you've
been so accepting I'm going to cry of
everything that I am because you're
lovely I'm all
right but
like it's uh it's scary being different
it wasn't anything about you it was the
world really no but I please you know
you don't have to mask in front of me
anymore that's why that's why I wanted
this video for you I wanted this film
tell you that but it's been really hard
to
go I've always been kind of acting yeah
didn't expect to get snotty I know you
want a tissue thank
you thanks for watching if you enjoyed
that be sure to check out these videos
next and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video